[Music]
hat forward out of the University of
Texas number 35
[Music]
Kevin two on one and he goes all the
[Applause]
way Kevin Durant way outside delivers
Kevin Durant from
[Music]
downtown L ladies and
gentlemen welcome back to the Bay a two
time Warriors world champion two times
the NBA Finals
MVP number
35 Kevin
dur leaving moments ago the Warriors
honored Kevin Durant with a tribute
video to thank him I asked Durant
earlier today about returning to the bay
to play he told me it's always good to
see old friends and reminisce about the
good times but I'm looking forward to
playing tonight first game of the season
it's always fun here in the Bay Area so
it's going to be electric I spoke with
Stephen Curry just before the game and I
asked him what his best memory of Kevin
Durant as a warrior was and predictable
guys he said uh June of 17 and 18 for
sure those are course the years they won
the championship together